where to move her that's the question i
guess i'd love to get rid of that bishop
um and this is a brilliant what a
brilliant move look at this stockfish
confirms that was the best move and ding
instantly reacted look at ding
devastated wow
how did he find that prague within
seconds that's a beautiful move your
queen was attacked but you kind of do a
bit of a crisscross you counter attack
against the black queen in the corner of
the board if black gets greedy now and
grabs the white queen black's queen
falls off as well white is going to be a
pawn up in a simplified position
what a move by prague incredible move
right important to find that
instantaneously with this crisscross
situation and that's put him in a
driving seat now if he can just hold on
to the time and yeah like you said david
it's ding's face it just dropped
immediately and he's done that a couple
of times today we have to show this
because it looked like white was in big
trouble this queen was attacked and next
move wherever she moves suddenly the
other black bishop would jump out taking
with the white bishop and look at these
two pieces dominant the white knight now
about to fall off